قالت وكاله توتاس للانباء ان السلطات
الروسيه فرضت حاله الطوارئ في منطقه خرسون
يساوي ارتفاع منسوب المياه بعد تفجيره سد
كخوفك كما اعلنت السلطات خرسون المواليه
لروسيا غرق نحو 2700 منزل واجلاء 1300 شخص
من المناطق التي غطتها المياه كما قال
عمده النوفا ان منسوب المياه في المدينه
بدا في الانحسار بعد ساعات من تفجير السد
وعلى الجانب الاوكراني تتواصل عمليه اجلاء
السكان
المتاثرين بتدمير السد فقال رئيس الاداره
العسكريه في خرسون ان المياه غمرت نحو
2000 منزل فضلا عن نجلاء الف وخمسمائه شخص
حتى الان وتوقع المسؤول الاوكراني ان
يرتفع مستوى المياه مترا اضافيا لافتا الى
ان تدفق المياه الناجم عن انفجار السد لم
يتوقف طوال الليل
الان الاكياف مع مراسل الجزيره عدنان
بوريني مرحبا بك معنا عدنان اذا ما هي
المعلومات المتوفره لديكم سواء حول منسوب
المياه وتدفقها او حتى الجهود الاوكرانيه
المتعلقه باجلاء الناس هناك
محمد تقدير الادارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه
في مناطق الجنوب يقول ان منسوب خزان
كخوفكا انخفض حتى الان مترين ونصف المتر
منذ تدمير السد مترين ونصف المتر محمد من
مما يمكن توصيفه ببحيره كبيره فلك ان
تتخيل كميه المياه التي انطلقت في مناطق
الغمر المتضرره هناك في خرسون بحسب
التقديرات فان هذه المناطق المتضرره سيكون
ايضا عليها تداعيات مستقبليه على اعتبار
ان هذا الخزان هو مصدرها يكاد يكون الوحيد
للمياه نتحدث عن مناطق زراعيه كبيره نتحدث
عن مناطق سكانيه كبيره السلطات الاوكرانيه
بشكل رئيسي محمد في هذه اللحظات تركز على
عمليات الاجلاء نتحدث عن نحو 17 الف
اوكراني في عشره مناطق بالاضافه الى عشرات
التجمعات السكانيه الاخرى 17 الف الاجلي
منهم نحو
حتى الان من المفترض ان يتم نقلهم او يتم
نقلهم حاليا الى ميكولايف ومدن اخرى بما
في ذلك العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف لاحقا على
احد التعبير الاولويه الاساسيه بحسب
تصريحات كل المسؤولين الاوكرانيين حاليا
هي حصر الاضرار او حصررها حتى بالنسبه
لهؤلاء السكان وتحدثنا بالامس عن ان هذا
العدد هو قليل نسبيا اذا ما قورنا بما قبل
الحرب على اعتبار ان المعارك الجاريه في
جبهه خيرسون خلصت اعداد السكان هناك نتيجه
عمليات النزوح جانب اخر مهم محمد في
المشهد بعد تدمير صدق خوفكا هو الجانب
السياسي كيف تترقب اليوم جلسه في مجلس
الامن طارئه كانت قد دعت اليها يفترض ان
تعقد في الساعه الحاديه عشره ليلا تسعى من
خلالها كييف بالاضافه الى خطوات اخرى لحشد
المشهد نحو عقوبات جديده على روسيا تستهدف
صناعه الصواريخ والصناعه النوويه على
اعتبار تصنيفها ما حدث
جريمه حرب لكن الامر الاهم الذي يترقبه
الجميع محمد هو البعد العسكري خرسون هي
جبهه مهمه للغايه تصنفك على انها جبه
هجوميه وبالنسبه لها وجبها دفاعيه بالنسبه
للقوات الروسيه بمعنى انها كانت تحاول
التقدم بشكل مستمر في تلك الجبهه والعبور
نحو الضفه اليسرى من الجبهه نائبه وزيره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه قالت ان روسيا حاولت
التضليل او ابعاد النظر عما تواجهه في
القرود من خلال تفجير السد قياده الاركان
الاوكرانيه قالت ان كل ذلك على ايه حال لن
يؤثر على سياق عملياتها الهجومي المستمر
وان القوات الروسيه بطبيعه الحال ما زالت
تتعامل بنسق دفاعي مستمر بقصف مناطق اخرى
ايضا في على الجبهه ذاته التقدير
الاستخبارات الذي قدم بالامس للرئيس
الاوكراني
بحسب ما اعلن الرئيس نفسه يقول بان روسيا
فجرت السد بحسب الروايه الاوكرانيه لكن
الرئيس قال بان التقدير قال ان روسيا فقدت
السيطره على هذا الموضوع واخطات الحسابات
مما ادى الى غمر معداتها العسكريه في
مناطق الغمر الواسعه جدا وهو ما قد يؤثر
على مسار المعارك بشكل كبير محمد